[Music]
small school we went to class together
we ate together everything else so it's
a big difference with you 40,000 people
going to school and you see him maybe
once a year so this was good for us to
this day we all stay in touch with each
other
muddy standards were well-endowed in all
of us he would let team pick the rules
but they had to be his rules in the 60
19 he always said every position he had
depth and people he could count on he
knew their character and we laugh
because he molded our character he
didn't give us any choice from an
academic standpoint if you had to go see
muddy and you were not doing so well in
the classroom he would chew you out
because academics was first we didn't
get any favors he just made sure that we
were doing the work as if it was not
going to class especially if he was
paying you know your tuition you were
better being class that's what you came
here for
well all the years I was here from 1967
to 1977 I graduated Hillsdale in 58
played on a 34 game winning streak team
played for the national championship in
1957 always likened to think of the 69
team like her 50:16 because we had a lot
of depth at every position when we went
out on the field we know we're gonna win
there wasn't any doubt about of just how
bad I was proud to be a part of it proud
to coach his fellows and they deserved
that
deserved everything that came to them
being on the team that was that just
brought us so close closer together we
still T in touch with a lot of the guys
and I've been waiting for this moment
for a long long time they're like
brothers and buddy was like dad
even for the coaching staff what we
learned on this team for me it's
probably the most rewarding experience I
can have to see teammates and recognized
because buddy always told me if there
was ever a team to recognize that would
be the one
[Music]
you